batting ninth 24 year old right-hander
peter lambert making his second start of
the season and his second career start
against the nationals owen won his
record against the nats with a start
back on july 23rd two years
[Applause]
ago this is trevor taking the field his
teammates pulled back and he was out
there for for a good you know 10 seconds
before everyone joined him
and that ball is well hit to left he got
around it and it's going to one hop the
wall over the head of rymel tapia lane
thomas
three for nine in the series now that
was loud here's the pitch and he reaches
for an off speed and grounds it left
side and mcmahon and story both going
for it they crisscross almost collide
mcmahon ends up with a ball but has no
play juan soto comes up at a good spot
runners on the corners and nobody out
and now the pitch soto swings it's a
high chopper right side krone catches
now throws to lambert covering and the
out is the call at first soto signaling
himself safe and pointing toward the
dugout for them to review that on the
play thomas scores escobar goes to
second either way soto will get his 94th
rbi of the year the nationals lead one
to nothing it looks like the nationals
are going to challenge this well you
know the throw beat him but lambert had
his foot in the air when he caught the
throw
soto
in on his hands and he fights it off for
a base hit
bob henley will stop escobar and then
that's open the afternoon with four hits
line is moving here in the top of the
first so double
infield single infield single
and then line drive single daniel
hernandez the hitter batting fifth left
hand hitting outfielder batting 276
eight doubles a triple nine homers 31
runs batted in is hit in five straight
nine of his last 10. here's the swing
and a ground ball wide of first second
baseman will field a long jam over there
at first with a flip to krone with a
pitcher lambert already covering
rogers makes the play four to three on
the slow roller escobar comes in from
third to score
soto to third bell to second it's the
nationals two of the rockies nothing
and trevor story will head to home plate
and this is going to find its way into
right field charlie
will stop at second would you say about
you know 50 mile an hour velocity it
just seems like it might be that kind of
day here yeah two on two out for the
rockies he's hitting 275 29 doubles a
triple 28 home runs and 89 runs batted
in
cj and a 3-0 knocks it into left center
field for a base hit blackman scores
story on his way to third it's a 2-1
washington lead c.j krohn with his 90th
run batted in ryan mcmahon the hitter
now
mack trying to keep it going hitting
from the left side against dispino and
he'll hit it to left field it's got some
carry hernandez to the wall it's gone
touch of all time opposite field
ryan mcmahon a three-run homer the
rockies go up four to two
the two two
swinging a ground ball up to third base
line nobody home it's a base hit along
the line tapia ranges over to pick it up
and will hold bell to a single so josh
bell hit that one against the defense
a little tapper up the third base line
with mcmahon playing off the line
and josh bell is two for two in this
ball game
he's right down the middle the pitcher
got a piece of it and it'll turn a
potential double play grounder into a
base hit so a hustle play there by bell
with the ball deflected by the pitcher
he thought it was going to be just first
and second but bell kept on running and
goes all the way to third on a ball that
barely reaches the outfield grass in
right field and so the nationals are in
a great chance here to do some damage
and erase this rocky's lead
swinging a line drive right field base
it toward the line this one's gonna go
all the way to the fence in the right
field corner bell headed home hernandez
on his way to third garcia into second
blackman's throw in his cut off that's
now the rockies four in the nationals
three rbi double into the right field
corner for luis garcia he picks up rbi
number 22. yeah this is crazy hunter
wino stats walking down the line he's
thinking about it and
i think he's going to make a move here
yeah that's it here comes the tarp all
right this game will be stopped with a
two and two count on paulo espino hustle
up gentlemen the field might be playable
still but it's just too dangerous so the
here come the ropes and here comes the
tarp pretty cool way to do it in quick
fashion so here we go after a two-hour
delay in the top of the third bases are
loaded two and two keep that in mind on
andrew stevenson
and he strikes out so
it was a short day at the office for
interest
pack up that locker go ahead pack up
your bag and get ready for the flight
now two outs
and elaine thomas the center fielder and
leadoff man to face godot right on right
and thomas corrects one to left
hernandez scores garcia coming in
and with two outs lane thomas will
deliver two run single for lane thomas
and the nationals are back in front by a
score of five to four
and this will load the bases for the
rockies with nobody out
past ball upbeat got it with 94. both
puts away mcmahon for out number one
base is loaded for sam sam hilliard over
one with the ground ball to third here's
the 2-1
and that's base hit to right center
field that'll put the rockies in front
blackman scores story will score
standing up
sam hilliard coming through
6'5 colorado the one-two from both swing
and miss blew it by him second strikeout
in the inning for both two down for
tapia the runners go again the 3-2 pitch
is hit on the ground softly towards
short backhanded by escobar he fires
onto first that's in time to get his man
returning
so godot
walks the lead off man for washington
here to begin the fifth inning the pitch
swag and a miss
good fastball down
strikeout number four for ashton goodell
the pitch
bounced right back to godot he goes to
second for one story to first double
play
rockies do it to the nationals again
halfway through six five rockies right
on right with colton welker as mcmahon
at second and nunes at first with one
out to colton welker and he rips it to
left field that'll get by hernandez
it'll go to the wall
mcmahon scores they'll hold nunes at
third rbi double colton welker
seven five rockies
pulled through the whole base hit
welker around third will get a stop sign
from stu cole as soto got to it quickly
eight fought colorado second hit of the
game for rybell and his 50th rbi tap off
and this one is in the air
to soto he'll get behind it and
coming down the lane is welker and he'll
score standing up with the rocky's ninth
run
so good at bat for rogers and there is
his 50th rbi and he's hit over 300 here
95 home runs
at coors field and this could be another
hit it will be getting under the glove
of uh alcitus escobar now he's trying
for a second
and
he's gonna be out there see uh with a
four-run lead worth a gamble he's given
everything
all the time i think trevor said he's
trying to leave it all on the field he
is definitely trying to leave it all on
the field and that is his fourth hit of
the ball game
see it go just under the glove of
escobar now the pitch to cj chrome
sweden is cracked in the air to deep
right soto back on this one to the track
at the wall feeling for the wall he
jumps and he makes the catch bangs into
the fence and comes up a little bit
hobbled three right-handed batters
against daniel bard
pitch bouncing ball to hopper handled by
cj crone he beats kibum to the bag one
out here in the washington eight one-two
pitch
swag and a miss he got him with the
slider daniel bart has retired the first
two here in the washington 802 pitch
hit towards right center field drifting
back but still room now the wind pushing
it around but sam hilliard stays with it
and daniel bart has a one two three top
of the eight
one more at bat here at home
in 2021 and for the
hardy
fans who have stayed here throughout
many of them on their feet
applaud trevor
if this is indeed his final home game in
iraqis uniform well the day remains
perfect trevor has reached for the fifth
time four singles and a wall
and mcmahon
with story coming home and trevor going
on contact will score which is nice for
back because it makes it a four rbi day
for ryan mcmahon and the rockies have
hit double figures ten to five two outs
now here in the ninth
bouncing ball to mcmahon he's got it and
that's the ball game the rockies in the
final home game of 20-21
they win convincingly 10-5 over the
knacks they take two of three in the
series